um what am i currently working on well
i'm trying to decide what on earth to do
with the game engine series
so all right all right stream so let's
break this down a little bit
right so i ran a little poll
let me just show this i ran a little
poll and i said
hey everyone those who watch care about
the game engine series
trying to decide how to continue um and
uh basically how do people feel about
the pacing
so 16 said it's too slow i want more
features faster
43 said i like the pace it's perfect
um uh 19 says slow down time explain
what we're doing and 22
why are we still doing 3d which is kind
of the same as it's too slow
so if we sum those together that's like
38 of people are saying that
it's too slow 43 of people are saying
it's
perfect and for some reason 19 want it
even slower than it already is which is
absurd
but anyway so um with this data in mind
uh basically 43 which if you think about
it is actually less than half
are happy with everything so that would
mean that 57
in some way the game engine series is
not perfect for them
which um to be honest i'm shocked that
43 like the pace because i thought this
number would be closer to like 20
um because in my opinion it's just
everything just way too slow like we're
just spending too much time
like well i mean i'm not wait i'm not
necessarily making episodes every week
but i do do things like game engine
series week every now and then to kind
of make up for a bit of that
but anyway the point is
we clearly are um
not really suiting everyone at this
point and so
what i want to do going forward is i
think that
even though 43 say that they're happy
with everything
there is still almost the same amounts
which are
which think that it's not like
evolving fast because again if you 22
plus 16 is 38
right so 38 of people which is very
close five percent off from 43
also think that it's not you know fast
enough so i guess
in my mind it's kind of like an even
split between these two it's just that i
gave more options to fit for people and
then
19 again slow down i think
this 19 i'm kind of going to ignore
because i actually am going to have
content coming out in the future
hopefully by the end of the year
um that's going to be specifically for
people who want more of like an actual
course that will teach like all the
details right
um but what's happening in my mind here
with the game engine series is that i
want to take it from
a tutorial series and take it into more
of like
not not like devlog territory but more
of like a
oh how do i how do i explain this um
like it's still going to be like a
how-to kind of tutorial series but it's
just that instead of writing
i think instead of writing all of the
code
and planning everything and going over
everything inside
each each episode what we're going to do
is
spend time developing the engine on this
live stream
and then make episodes
out of that by probably
pulling in code from diffs and doing a
little bit more of what we did
in i think the little i think when i did
the event system i kind of experimented
with that format and i think back
then it was probably didn't make sense
but now
it's yeah i think that i don't know i i
just think that it's it's not gonna be
it's not gonna be like feasible to go
forward
without without spending like more time
actually developing this stuff on stream
and then picking out the kind of uh good
stuff
from that okay anyway um yeah number
four number one for not at all the same
i think they
are because um lots of people are
you know i i've been paying attention to
like the discord channel and a lot of
people are just
not happy with the fact that the series
is not progressing quickly right and
they
you know 3d is kind of like a
measurement of how fast the series is
progressing because we said we would do
2d first and then we would do 3d and so
clearly
we're still on 2d and we're barely on 2d
i mean if you look at this stuff
like it looks very three-dimensional but
we're basically we're still kind of
working to
to build the 2d stuff up and we can't
it's not like you can make a game with
this you know in 2d
so um clearly like in terms of the game
engine series it's not
really going um very quickly
which you know i mean is fine because
apparently 43
of people are happy with it um
but i i'm not sure that i am and also i
have to think about
how much time the game engine series is
taking me to actually do
per week because as we get more and more
complicated
right naturally this series is going to
take more and more time
um and i because the game engine series
for me is like
the least viewed thing on my entire
channel
um like each episode of the game engine
series when i put that out that just
gets the least amount of views
um i know that there's a good core
audience that really likes it
but i still have to think about how much
time i put into that
compared to things that clearly more
people appreciate
um so uh it's also a bit of a balancing
act so i can't just like
devote myself fully to this game engine
series because there's just not enough
people watching it
um i guess is my point um and also
because
like i still want to do it of course and
i still want to develop
it but i also really want to work on
hazeldev and
other kind of you know i don't just want
to spend all my time teaching
how to make a game engine
my cat's just standing in front of my
light and it's probably gonna like crash
in a minute
don't do that anyway
i can't spend all my time teaching how
to make a game engine
and then not actually make a game engine
because then i'm just
like some academic and yeah
what is my best viewed show well
anything like c plus series probably
gets the most views c plus plus series
like the hazel dev vlogs usually get
more views than
um everything basically
the game engine series like a lot of
those episodes have under 10 000 views
like in the beginning like the ones back
in the day were better but it's just
but that's inevitable it's it's just
that's just the way that a
extremely long series goes you know
there's no way that
through like we've done like i think
almost 100 episodes like
you know who who has watched all of them
and is up to date with all of them you
know that's clearly going to be a
smaller
number than say like the c plus plus
series where
like hey the latest one was about like
binary and bitwise operators like you
don't need anything else to watch that
video you can just jump right in
but to watch the latest episode of the
game engine series let's just watching
it for fun
like you kind of need to have watched
the other like 70 or 80 videos which is
obviously going to reduce the audience a
lot so i understand why it's happening
and it's not like i'm surprised
i've done very long series pretty much
throughout the whole life of my channel
like the game
programming series which i started in
2012.
that thing had has 126 episodes like
when i stopped it
you know so um
my point being that any long series is
going to
see a decline in viewership anything you
know you look at any series on youtube
the first episode has like the most
views
the second episode has like half the
views and then it just keeps going down
that's just the way that it is
but because that's the way that it is um
i also need to
uh i guess consider my time because
lately like again because i've been so
busy with stuff going on in my real life
like outside of work um i
have to be a little bit more disciplined
i guess with my time and i'm still
trying to work out
how best to do this because i'm not
happy at all with how much time i've
been putting into like the game engine
series for example and even into hazel
um and into other videos like i kind of
there's too much stuff going on like
even in work there's like you know the
whole hazel dev situation there's c
plus plus series the game engine series
like there's other videos that i want to
make that are more creative maybe like
how to make games using hazel and
there's just too much stuff going on and
i need to uh
kind of be a little bit more i think
putting my foot down with certain things
anyway that's a bit of a rant about the
state of things
um basically what i want to do today
though is actually spend time thinking
about
how this game engine series is going to
progress which is why i'm happy that you
guys are here i really wanted to do this
live so that it's more of a discussion
why are you what are you doing
yeah see like a lot of the comments are
even like this one i'm doing your opengl
tutorials right now
can't wait to start these i'm currently
following your opengl series can't wait
to start this like these people aren't
even actually watching these videos
you know what i mean that's what i'm
saying like i
clearly like like it or not you know
this is
like i don't really want to create like
a a
course you know like a university course
that 20 people will eventually
dedicate their lives to and complete
because first of all i don't think i'm
good enough to make a complete course on
a game engine like that's difficult
i'm more or less doing this kind of
stuff as like a hobby for fun
obviously to teach people what i know
but like it's not it's never going to be
like a
you know it's almost like i don't i
don't feel comfortable asking people to
commit
you know a year to just go through like
eventually the series of complete videos
and then learn all there is to know
about game engines because i just don't
think that that's
especially youtube is the right space
for that you know so
therefore how do i take this and still
keep it
fun and still have it be really like
well no sorry let's back off from the
fun for a bit how do i keep this
educational
how do i actually make this um
[Music]
you know really informative and to
benefit people who want to learn more
about game engines
but then also um
kind of take that down i guess and also
keep it
more accessible to casual viewers and
more fun
so that's kind of that's a tough thing
to do um
and i think that what would be
interesting is again if i took
everything
and i i summarized it a lot more
yes there's gonna be more bitwise videos
there's still two more videos in that
series
um maybe one next week or if not
definitely the week after
um okay so
and see again people asking for small
projects to take two videos to finish
this is a classic
little sign of lack of commitment like
meaning that like
that's just how people on youtube are
you know you can't i don't think you can
expect people to watch 30 hours of
content on youtube and if you can it's
going to be a subset of it
so my point is it's not really the the
um optimal platform something like
a course website like uh you um udemy
for example
is more i think more suited towards
something like that
um because that's like that's a lot more
serious and therefore you don't really
even need
that many people to be because it's like
a paid platform you don't really need
need like hundreds of thousands of
people to watch it for it to be really
viable to me career out of
you can have like 5 000 students or
whatever and that's still good enough
so i think something like that is
probably going to be more serious this
anyway
um so the fact that this is on youtube
uh just means that it i think that it
would be optimal for it to be slightly
different
so event system the thing is people
hated this this video
and people say that they prefer the old
format and they'd rather watch longer
episodes
the real time decision making is
something that people want to watch
that's why i'm i'm still thinking about
this and i haven't made this decision
why because what i did here again was i
think i just
went through like already written code
or i went through
diffs because i think even then i was
like typing out all this code is going
to be nuts
see i went through diffs so the other
thing that i could do
and and this is what i'm thinking of
doing actually is
um and this was my original idea
actually before i started this stream as
well
is what i could do is i could
like because like it or not i'm still
gonna have to work out how to do
everything
right that has to happen regardless of
whether or not it makes
it into the video or if it stays it's
just something that i do offline right
it has to happen
like for example i'm doing a material
system i can't just
start making a video on a material
system i mean i could but it would be
very messy and very long
so what i what i have to do first right
is i have to plan it
i have to plan it i have to try it i
have to
potentially see it fail i have to
rethink the design i have to
re-implement it
i have to maybe optimize it or think
about how we can actually make it work
better with the rest of the api
like my point is something like a
material like something
even as basic as like okay i want
materials and i want
us to be able to store uniforms in a
material class and then
have that be something that we that our
renderer could use
right something even as simple as that
could take eight hours
of actually my time right because
i don't know no software engineer is
going to be like oh yeah material system
for a game engine i'll knock that out in
30 in a 30 minute episode
like that's not gonna happen and even in
like two hours that's still for 30
episodes there's still quite a bit but
that's like that's not that's that might
not be enough time right so my point is
it's gonna take a lot of time
right and me waving my hands around is
gonna provoke my cat to attack me so
please do not do that
anyway so what i could do right and what
i'm thinking of doing is
that whole process that whole process
of planning and implementing and testing
and like the part that isn't really like
say an episode of the game engine series
like it's just kind of like the working
out what to do
so for example like that mouse picking
live stream actually i posted that mouse
picking planning live stream on youtube
um and so that was like a huge hour and
a half thing i think or
it was over now definitely um how did
that do views wise
um because that i think was um
let me just go to my channel actually um
because that so what was that how i work
it's 26 000 views so see even this did
way better than like fourteen thousand
nine thousand
seven point three thousand twelve
thousand so clearly this actually did
better and it was an hour and a half
so that's actually a little bit
surprising to me um but you know again
it's just
it's more generic sounding it's not like
game engine series people probably
thought it was more interesting than it
actually was maybe um but i guess people
did like this style of video but then
again you know whenever i post a video
and i'm like hey you know if you guys
like this style of video everyone's like
of course we did
so it's also i can't really trust that
necessarily too much especially for
different people commenting every time
um anyway so my point being that what i
could do
is still basically when i plan the game
engine series when i try and experiment
with and do all of that stuff
i could still stream it so that it looks
like this video
right and if you guys are lost as to
what i mean because you're new to the
stream or whatever you can always look
at this
because this is in fact the live stream
basically and what i could do
is stream that on twitch
right um and then that way people
actually can people who really want the
long form content can still watch that
and then i guess what i would do do not
scratch my monitor so what people
so people who actually want the
long-form content people who for some
reason want to see every single minute
of every work that goes into hazel they
can still do that by watching the live
streams
um but i guess what i would do because
currently my live stream vods are only
for
subscribers um and if i did do this to
the game engine series i don't really
want to
like tell people that you have to you
literally have to pay
to get this content um i probably make
my vods public
because they stay up for 60 days anyway
so what i would do
i guess in that scenario would be i
would publish
i would take my vods and i would upload
them to youtube for patrons like
currently do with the rest of all of my
live streams
right and that's like five bucks a month
so that's not like a huge
you know investment i think from people
um and so if you didn't have time to
watch them in the first 60 days
or you want to go back and watch the
whole catalogue then you can
do that otherwise for the first 60 days
they're free because that's how long
twitch keeps votes around
and then still you get the summary
episodes on youtube
um so that way again people who just
want to want to catch up
with the game engine series and see a
more casual approach
um and just see like the summary of so
these are the code changes that went in
these are the decisions i made this is
why
and now it works and now it does this
and me explaining certain areas of the
code
that would be what the actual game
engine series would be like on youtube
and then raw stream uploads again um
they like the actual streams of the
whole process which
again for a 20 minute resulting video
might be eight hours of content right or
might be four hours of content i don't
know
but that would be available on twitch
for people to watch
for free but also on youtube
for patreons so i'll still keep that as
kind of like more exclusive content
because i think a good good way for
people to actually actually support
the series but also you can watch it for
free for 60 days so i think that's fair
um because after 60 days twitch will
just delete it
yeah and and again um uh what i'm saying
is that yeah the the
uh the the the concept of how game
engine is built and those like decisions
and stuff
would obviously be in a summary video
because that would be more about talking
about stuff yeah
so that's kind of what i'm thinking at
the moment um i
i think that possibly that would be good
um and maybe every now and then if i
have like a particularly nice live
stream like that mouse one where it's
like just me working for an hour and a
half
and i'm talking a lot and everything is
working and nothing's failing and it's
fun to watch
that i might every now and then post
those full raw streams on youtube
on my main channel but otherwise they
would just be
probably stream exclusive for some
features it might be interesting to go
through the process backwards
start by describing the end product and
then talk about the differences from
other versions and why you decide to
change them well yeah exactly
like i'm sure some summary videos would
be like that personally i became a
sponsor because i value the focus
content i want to support you making
more of it
generally much care for the live coding
streams but what do you mean by focused
content
because like the focus content um i i
guess you mean like
directly how to do this and that that's
already been prepared and not just like
hours of
but see that's what i mean like if i was
to record videos of me
developing the more complex features of
the engine that would be ours
and that wouldn't be as focused as like
a summary video which is why i think
that would work really well
i saw that some people instead of typing
code from scratch on video just paste
code
written beforehand after explaining it
that's kind of what i would do with the
diff
but i don't think i would i would just
show the dips i wouldn't paste it in
unless there were like iterations that i
thought were really useful to
show i mean i don't really see a
downside because
i guess in a way what i'm doing is
hopefully
just saving time and also
providing people with more concise
content because the way i see this is
okay
so let's just say we do the material
system let's just say that it takes
eight hours of me
planning and implementing and making
sure that it works and testing and
setting up okay so eight hours let's
just say it's taken eight hours right
so after i do the eight hours of that i
now need to record a video
like let's just say this is the old game
engine series format the
one that we have now so then in that
case okay eight hours okay so there's a
lot of code to type
a lot of code to explain so what would i
have to do i'd have to break it
up into like i don't know four videos
maybe
right and maybe they'd be each like 30
minutes or whatever i think that that
would probably be enough
right so now i have to record four
videos in which i
partially you know take code that i've
written as part of their material system
rewrite it in front of everyone explain
all of it
and then obviously that results in
basically one episode per week so that
one stream or without one day that i
spent
making like doing all the material
system in eight hours
right unless you say i streamed that
whole thing i would then have to make us
four videos and then release them i
guess probably once a week so that's
four weeks so basically that whole
material system takes
like a month to do right
or the plan b it is and and not only
that right but it's almost like it's a
little bit redundant because
i mean i mean you um you guys know me
anyway when i stream and when i program
like i usually explain everything i'm
doing so it's not like these videos are
suddenly going to be so much more in
depth
they're going to be maybe a little bit
more in depth but sometimes these
streams are even better because you guys
ask questions and that that might be
stuff that i don't really think about
when i'm
recording a video because i obviously
don't like a chat or anything like that
right
so in other words the content is there
it's just eight hours of it and so me
breaking it up into four videos
i'm not saying it wouldn't be useful at
all i'm just saying that that's
obviously going to take a lot of time
and it's going to be spread out spread
out over four weeks
and um in a way it's going to be the
same content as the
hour stream but just boiled down and
simplified and
kind of streamlined i guess because
there's no like experimentation anymore
unless it's really beneficial for
education um it's more just like let's
implement this
so alternatively the alternative path is
that still that eight hour live stream
still happens because i still physically
need to work out how to do the material
system
but then what we do is we make a single
video
that is basically me showing the
material system in action
showing all of the code diffs walking
through the code basically doing a code
review
honestly doing a code review um showing
it
and then integrating it in one 30 minute
video
that's released on that same week
possibly even the next day
after that eight hour live stream in
which i've written all of this
so that obviously is a lot more rapid
the series will progress much faster
but also i don't have to spend so much
time going through everything
and more importantly people watching
don't have to be like ugh
the fourth episode on the material
system
i'm sick of this because it's such a you
know it's one thing to write the code
and it's one thing to sit here in visual
studio and like write the code for the
material system that's kind of fun
but to watch videos you know the reason
why
i've also been thinking about this guys
is because i've been thinking about the
videos that i watch
right i've been thinking about um
i've been thinking about the programming
videos that i watch because i do not
watch
any videos that are like mine on youtube
right
i don't what i do watch is things like
sebastian's
code adventures or well you know various
i guess i watch
quite a bit of various devlogs from
people and like for example like yeah
we'll devlog but i was trying to think
more of like because sebastian stuff uh
that's not really it
it's not so much a devlog because he
actually like it's like it's like a
whole project in one video and i really
like that but anyway
you know that kind of stuff um yeah like
you know
dev some devlogs are a bit more
technical they're good but anyway
my point is i like watching that um and
and then i also watch like
uh gdc talks and various like siggraph
talks and
various other kind of talks because
again what is that that's like an hour
of someone explaining everything and
that's fun to watch it's kind of like
it's a summary
right what i what i don't watch is
people programming
live and showing me how to do everything
step by step why
because for me it's way more efficient
to just look at the code
right and maybe like some comments or
maybe if it's like some really weird
like algorithm
watching a video that explains that
algorithm would also be beneficial right
but watching someone like write a game
engine for me like it's different i
guess because obviously you guys are
um i mean probably you know don't have
as much experience
um making game engines that i do but my
point is i feel like
at this point where we've talked about
this so much and you've followed the
series
you should probably start becoming more
that person than like
okay i need to you know get to the stage
of like a full 3d
game engine with c integration and i
want every line of code written for me
and i wanted every line of code
explained and i want everything to be
to be seen right because um
i i don't think that that's helpful for
people because that like if you require
that you're clearly still a baby in
terms of like your experience and your
how comfortable you are programming um
so
that's uh that's not good because then
why are you building a game manager and
what why have you gotten to this point
in a game engine and you still can't do
things yourself like that's weird
um and i don't think that i don't think
that's healthy or helpful
um so anyway uh so but summary videos
that explain concepts and also
show the implementation i'm not saying
i'm not gonna show the code i'm just
saying that i'm not gonna
physically type it in front of people
because it's getting to the point where
it's just inefficient to do that and i
think that it's not
it's not helpful for the people who are
actually trying to learn from this stuff
unless you're just following this along
blindly and
you want every code written because you
just want to type and learn that way
which
i'm sure is maybe like 10 20 of people
but i don't think that that's
a good way for them to go i think that
if they put more effort into it
and um actually uh wrote you know
actually watched like a summary video or
maybe listen to the concept
try to integrate it themselves first and
then looked at my diff and my solution
that would be way better
um all right how about a video with cut
parts of the stream well that's probably
going to be too much
because um like maybe actually i could
actually almost do a commentary over the
stream
um and then show bits written in the
string that's not a bad idea i might
depending on how the streams end up
though because sometimes it won't be
good
um it wouldn't be okay so um
maggot magette sub magette sub
i still don't know how to pronounce your
name man i've you've seen i've seen you
around the stream for like years but i
still don't understand
anyway um so if you don't enjoy code
review videos
um what uh okay so but but you do enjoy
the current game industries
why like what do you how do you watch it
how do you consume that content and
do you type the code along with the
videos or what do you do do you just
watch them
i'm interested i think if you
really can split example materials as
much as topics like multiple videos are
fine
i'm not saying it's not fine i'm just
saying it's a lot of time
and it's very slow progress that's the
problem
um when i want to learn about general
engine structure i browse github well
exactly like i feel like most people
should
you know at this point in a game engine
like of course if it's like opengl
or very basic game engine architecture
typing out the code would be very
useful but you know we've got a decent
project here
you know i usually like write any code
while watching the videos but i love
seeing the thought process
um okay yeah we'll see that that's what
i mean
the thought process is something that we
can capture in those summary videos
um and if you really want the extended
thought process because that's the other
thing right
those videos are fake in a way i used to
do them completely
spontaneous like as in i used to not
plan them at all i used to sit down and
be like okay today we're going to
implement a layer system
and i would do all of it live in the
video like it wouldn't be live streamed
this was back like two years ago maybe
but um for the first like 20 30 episodes
of the series they were completely
unplanned they were all done
live just by me recording and then
sometimes if there'd be mistakes i'd
edit them out or i'd redo them but
that's it you know because it was so
simple back then
and i could manage everything in my head
i knew how everything would kind of
come together but now like
i can't just write a material system
without knowing how it's going to work
i need to actually type the code in and
debug it and do all that stuff
which again nothing wrong with that but
it's just very long this is a very long
process if i'm watching something long
format it's to hear
thought process in the moment well
exactly and that brings me back to this
fake
fake stuff that i was talking about so
what used to happen
is it used to be real in the sense that
like because it really was my first time
going through the code
it was my real thought process but now
since i do the planning and live streams
anyway
and then i record the episode it's a
fake thought process it's not a in the
moment thing it's me trying to recreate
what i already know
which again makes for a better video you
could argue because it's way more
concise
and i know what i'm doing but this is
not the genuine thought process so if
you wanted the genuine thought process
you would have to watch the live stream
so either way that doesn't work you know
what i mean
shorter format generally means i'm
trying to implement something smaller or
specific
well yeah but also you might want like i
guess a summary of how something works
like
you know um i wouldn't like i wouldn't
mind
um you know i wouldn't mind watching for
example like a video of
someone explaining how their material
system in their game engine works
um and maybe even showing like all the
code to implement it because that that's
kind of interesting
but if they were typing out the whole
thing over hours then i just
don't have time to watch that and also
it wouldn't be helpful for me
and again like i'm trying to i'm trying
not to
make this series like so selfish in a
way like because obviously like this
series is not
for me i don't need this series meaning
that like i don't need to watch this
series
um like i would never i'm not the target
audience is my point
so i have to picture like what you guys
and that's why i'm kind of doing this in
this live stream to try and figure out
what's going on
because i don't think that um
i don't think that it's helpful
if i just kind of make all these
decisions myself without even
finding out more about the audience and
like i don't know like i do read
comments
and stuff but like you know most people
just consume most people don't really
write comments
and so it's not easy and with the that's
why the poll was kind of useful because
that's easy just press the button and
you know but that's kind of it like
shorter 20 minute videos that overviews
how system works
yeah so that's that's kind of what i'm
thinking of doing
i think you can make every single person
happy with whatever it is the format you
chose personally i think we could get
best of both sides with the format sort
of like the hazel dev
devlogs yeah well i don't really want to
make it
like the hazel devlogs because
the uh hazel devlops are very
shallow that like i don't really show
any code i think it's more of like
hey these are the new features um
you know that we've added and this is
what you can do now because it's
supposed to be more like an entertaining
thing like oh cool what does hazeldev
have you know how's channel's engine
going
it's more of just that i'm making a
project hey guys want to check it out
um so i don't really like i do want to
make some more in-depth videos where i
actually go into the code and discuss it
a bit
and show stuff i have some plans for
that i don't know why i haven't gone
around to doing that yet
but um that is in the works i guess
um but again the uh
having it a little bit more kind of um
you know but by having it like a little
bit more in-depth meaning like actually
writing the code and stuff i think it's
gonna be better i don't mind the focus
of pre-planning video it's pretty
obvious that you don't
copy up with an elegant sign at the
outset
um yeah
no well no i'm just saying that for
people who are like i want your
your genuine process of implementing
something like that
the game engine series is not really a
good indication of my genuine
process of working that's why that video
that stream that i did post the mouse
picking one
that's on youtube that one is that's
i titled it how i work because that was
real you know
um that's all not genuine but that's
sort of how programming really is the
client does not see everything that went
through making a product they just see
the product
well yeah but i again i'm just talking
about people who say that i like that
you type out all the code in the videos
because it shows your thought process
and i want to see that
to those people i'm just saying that
it's better to do that
like it's better it's better to watch
the live streams anyway because it's not
real even though it might look real
because i'm
pretty good at acting but it's not a lot
of it's very script
like scripted it's not actually on a
script but i um
i play it up for the for the episode
sometimes
like is it i make it look like oh no but
but this doesn't work but then i'm
actually like
that's because we need to do this but
that's already i've been through that
you know and i deliberately wrote that
code
the way it was because i thought that
maybe it'd be easier for people who
might run into the same problem to see
how to recognize the solution and how
like why it's a problem and to
demonstrate that no but again i think
that like you know people are saying oh
well you can't please everyone but
but in a way i think i can't currently
with this new plan i kind of
am because i'm still keeping those live
streams they'll be up
and if you want to watch one from half a
year ago and it's no longer on twitch
you can pay five bucks and get access to
all of them on patreon you know
which i don't think is is it really a
problem and you'll be obviously helping
to support the series
but if you're okay with the summary
videos
then they'll be on youtube and i and
they won't be just
code reviewers as in like looking
through diffs being like so we we added
this because uh
we needed to do this to get it to work
and uh
no they're not gonna be like that
they're gonna be like me actually
showing stuff
and like hey guys what's up let's talk
about this maybe let's even draw a
diagram to explain how this
works kenny thanks so much for your
subscription welcome to the stream
um you know it's gonna be that kind of
stuff like it's not gonna be as
stupid as like a as stupid i guess
as just a shoot like a code review that
you would expect in an
office because that's even code reviews
in an office
can sometimes be decent like it's just
kind of
i don't know man it's it's i don't want
to make it boring i'm still going to
make it
fun you know um it's going to be like
yeah
same old me and same you know same thing
but just
instead of literally typing everything
in fact i think it'll be more engaging
because there'll be less
less time for me to like you know type
stuff
they'll be more about like actually
discussing the code
which again you know that that's what i
mean by these things like people who
people who are a little bit more
intermediate maybe and less beginner
level
they don't need to watch me type code
like to them that's a waste of time
like why would they want to watch
someone painstakingly
write out hundreds of lines of code like
that is
such a waste of time and yes i talk over
that and sometimes i try and
say as much as i can while typing the
code so it's not just like
you know silence while i'm typing away
and
making and writing code because that
would be even worse but still
it's like to me as an engineer
it just doesn't make any sense why would
anyone want to watch that you know why
would anyone want to watch that if they
can get the same content but instead of
typing
everything you can explain it and since
you don't have to wait to finish typing
you can move on immediately instead of
just being like all right so
i'll explain yourself to right quickly
write this if statement
like it just doesn't make any sense
kenny's saying really enjoy the vids
channel finally caught up on game
industry a few weeks ago building a
hobby engine they've been helpful
encouraging great great to hear because
we're currently discussing them
and uh what we're gonna do well
unfortunately streams are not as smooth
in terms of mistakes as videos of course
well yeah but but but for the audience
that wants to see the mistakes because
they want to learn from them and see
like how i work and what my process is
which people were talking about in the
chat before
those streams are perfect for them and
that's why
obviously since you've mentioned that
they're not smooth and they're very long
and so they'll never be the game engine
series on youtube because
people don't know i don't think most
people want to watch hours and hours of
content to do this one little thing
they'd rather see um more or less a much
more concise thing
but my point is it's coming to it's
we're getting to the point where
even the concise current format of the
game engine series
is still going to be ours because we're
getting into more complex topics
and so that's why i'm saying if we if we
make it more summarized and we make it
even more concise but again still every
line of code will be shown and explained
and
the diffs will be on github anyway
because it's public you know everything
will be there
it's not like it's suddenly like up now
i'm going to draw you guys a diagram and
that's that's it sorry work out the code
yourselves it's not like it's becoming
that you know um
i like also what um uh uh ob van
oban 1052 said the series yeah the
series is complex now so level of
viewers should be too
exactly the series should the viewers
should grow with the series
that's the ideal plan and so if you're
still like you know imagine that like
this engine is like unreal and we want
to
add you know some kind of better
animation blending support what are we
really going to write every line of code
for that and be like all right so this
is me doing this now
like no like that doesn't make any sense
in my opinion code videos only make
sense for stuff that people can easily
replicate an environment they're
learning comfortable
well exactly for beginners it's great
because they can just literally
they can literally just follow line by
line
and they will um get the same result as
you
and i i know from my experience as a
beginner like 10 years ago for me
actually watching someone write the code
line by line
and me copying it that was by far the
best place
because i could actually see that person
writing
every single line of code and i could
reproduce the same result
through code and that was magic to me
back then so
i understand the beginners wanting that
but again that's why we have
you know the courses for beginners and
why we have the
first 100 episodes of the game engine
series which is um
um actually
how many episodes are there of the game
engine series i have a
92 i think we're 92 because in my
in my production folder um
92 is like the code name for the latest
episode
so unless i'm i lost count somewhere but
92 episodes of the game edges so it's
like 100 basically almost a hundred plus
a separate batch rendering videos and
more that was a good split yeah
because that was again a part that
didn't really have to be tied to the
game engine series
um and where possible i like to do that
because simply because they just do
better they get more views they
help more people you know because
um because they're not tied into
80 episodes of prerequisites you know
a medical student but i usually join
your stream in my free time just to
enjoy oh that's cool man
lion man thanks for watching the stream
glad you are enjoying
it and again by reviewing code it's not
necessarily going to be like a code
review for those of you who know what a
code review is like
because like you've worked as a software
engineer or whatever like it's not
really
going to be like that it's going to
still be
explanations and teaching
build up series can be hard to pull off
on youtube people lose track quickly
i don't know what you mean what you mean
by build up series but yes
most people lose track quickly of like
any kind of series on youtube
you know someone someone even the most
dedicated person might be like yes like
i can't wait to follow this video
every week it's released you know oh
they come out on thursday nights or
sunday nights or whatever i'm gonna
allocate a couple hours to actually do
the code
you can start off like that and you can
last a while but when you get into like
the third year of these videos man life
changes like that you know who's who is
still from the first episode
who is still like oh jedi's releasing
your video tonight you know i'm still
in get no like whoever whoever started
the game engine series
in 2018 when it started i think it
started in 2018.
um whoever started it back then and is
still
up to this point and has not done
anything else
is seriously wasting their time unless
this is just like a chill activity that
they're doing
as a hobby that they don't really care
about they're just doing it for fun you
know then i could imagine like if it's
really really low priority for you and
you're just living life and it's like oh
cool i'll do this now
hey scott dev thank you for your seven
months of subscriptioning
glad to have you here doesn't get
repository solve that beginner's need
following my line yeah yeah well again
it does but it's still not
not like lines they don't they're not
explained
you know what i mean like th the summary
might be more useful because it actually
will have like a diagram and it will
potentially have a diagram and like i'll
at the very least i'll explain it
verbally
so it's obviously more than a diff um
but then on the other hand if it was
line by line
people who might want an explanation
have to sit through line by line
programming for no reason
and a lot of extra talking from me
because i need to fill up the silence
while i'm typing the code
and many more hours of content than they
need and also don't forget that it's not
even about people watching it's about me
making those videos
i could be spending those hours
developing something else like working
on hazel
um on hazeldev producing more videos
doing other stuff
you know so that's it's also um kind of
important to consider that
and because because it is less time not
even working on other stuff maybe even
working on this
but just getting further in the series
because you don't have to spend time
don't have to spend a month on the
material system can do it in a week
instead